this is a major story we're starting
with today republicans have been caught
in a series of presentations audio
recordings and powerpoints openly
planning to win elections not by
actually winning the hearts and minds of
voters and getting people to the polls
and winning elections in a real way
they've been caught planning to win by a
strategic and concerted effort
to just contest ballots to claim fraud
and this plan in and of itself is a form
of voter fraud
we are going to listen to the recordings
we are going to look at what we have
learned
and one of the things that i said back
in 2020
when six months before the november 2020
election donald trump and others started
saying oh it's going to be fraud he
would say fraud he would say the paper
ballots uh the mail-in ballots absent
it's all fraudulent they're going to try
to take it it's going to be insecure
and what i said at the time was you know
at some point in the future
they are actually going to attempt
massive voter fraud and we're going to
call them out and then they're going to
say oh come on you're the guys who said
there was no fraud when we were pointing
to the fraud in 2020 and that is
happening right now because remember
with republicans with the modern right
wing in the united states
every time they make an allegation
we should consider and explore whether
it's actually a confession of something
they're planning to do oh hillary can't
be trusted with with sensitive
information trump's eating documents
flushing documents and stealing
documents to mar-a-lago
when they say the left is doing
something the first question we should
ask is are they actually the ones doing
this is that how they think it's
something someone might do because they
are the ones doing it so
they are conspiring to win elections win
by contesting ballots of democrats not
by actually convincing people to vote
for them explosive political report
it's going to be an army tapes reveal
republican plan to contest elections
placing operatives as poll workers and
building a hotline to friendly attorneys
are among the strategies to be deployed
in michigan and other swing states this
is incredibly important stuff to know
about now because if we're not ready to
fight this
they could get away with it think about
we you know thank goodness they didn't
get away with it in 2020 but you could
argue that it was a trial run and that
they're going to try again and there's
every indication they're going to
heidi prisbilla for politico quote video
recordings of republican party
operatives meeting with grassroots
grassroots activists provide an inside
look at a multi-pronged strategy to
target and potentially overturn votes in
democratic precincts they're targeting
the democratic precincts install trained
recruits as regular poll workers and put
them in direct contact with party
attorneys the plan is outlined by a
republican national committee staffer in
michigan includes utilizing rules
designed to provide political balance
among poll workers to install
party-trained volunteers prepared to
challenge voters as democratic majority
polling places
at democratic majority polling places
developing a website to connect workers
to local lawyers and establishing a
network of party-friendly das who could
intervene to block vote counts at
certain precincts so here's the strategy
okay
most polling places generally speaking
have a system for
poll workers
and poll watchers
most of those systems are designed that
there be partisan balance you can't have
all democrats watching a poll a polling
place or all republicans
the idea would be you have a partisan
balance
but these are all just kind of
good faith people who are there
genuinely to make sure that everything
is being done in the correct way the
republican plan is to take advantage of
the rules which say you have to have
some democrats and some republicans
there has to be balance
and to train the republican poll workers
to understand how to disproportionately
challenge democratic votes by virtue of
being in overwhelmingly democratic
precincts
uh in order to have balance on paper
listen we've still got democratic poll
workers and republican poll workers it's
all fine but the republican workers that
are poll workers that are there
are there not to make sure everything is
on the up and up
but they are there because these are
left-leaning precincts where they are
going to try to help republicans by
challenging votes that will
statistically be more likely to be
democratic rather than republican votes
being a poll worker you just have so
many more rights and things you can do
to stop something than as a poll
challenger
so again the idea here is
don't have them there
as the obviously partisan poll
challengers have them there just as
regular poll workers who are going to
say they're seeing funny business we
have audio recordings let's take a
listen to one understand that we are
upset with the 2020 results but we
cannot just look at the 2020 results or
else the exact same thing will happen in
2022. we need volunteers on the ground
on election day ahead of election day
working
so that that fraud does not happen again
if we only look at 2020 it just will
happen i worked the polls the last
election
and not only were we extremely poorly
trained i mean badly trained but when we
caught them cheating and i caught them
cheating
they they had a pre-planned thing that
they did they would swarm you they
blocked you from seeing things they
accused you of doing things that you
weren't doing and then they would go
like this and you have the police coming
out so that that's why we're here now
today 13 months ahead of exactly
as opposed as opposed to one month ahead
of it so if i could ask everyone just to
listen to matt and by the way the reason
that they're saying 13 months is the the
recordings from october these recordings
were just recently published so they're
talking about october 2021 13 months
before this coming november election
this plan is for the november election
and go through his presentation
then we can ask questions afterwards
that would be greatly appreciated
but seriously that's why we're on the
ground like rob said it's so early to
address exactly that right the democrats
and i'm
um we are trying to recruit truly it's
going to be an army right we are going
to try to recruit lawyers we're going to
have more lawyers than i've ever been
recruited because let's be honest that's
where it's going to be fought right
we're going to have lawyers that work
early to build relationships with
different judges so that when that
happens we're going to have lawyers that
have relationships with the police
chiefs in the different areas
the police chief the police so you're
going to have
install republican
uh bad faith poll workers
to contest ballots
have them be in touch with lawyers
and the lawyers know the police chiefs
so maybe they can even involve police in
helping to skew the elections in their
favor
so when that happens those pre-existing
relationships are already established so
that they can't lie so that they can i
i've talked with so many people that
work at the tcf center and that i've
heard that happens it happened right no
one is just like it happened and it's
wrong that it happened it's 100 wrong
that it happened and we're going to
address it we're going to address it by
having the lawyers on the ground we're
going to address it by trying to have it
so the plan is as follows in most places
in many places we'll talk about detroit
michigan because this is one one place
that this is becoming a very big deal
um the poll workers have to be selected
from names submitted by each of the
parties
great
so
we know that detroit is a particularly
blue part of michigan so if you want to
skew a state election
you don't know whether a particular
voter is a republican or a democrat so
you say okay well listen if michigan is
in general is a i don't know what the
numbers are imagine it's a 52 to 48
state or a 5545 democratic leaning state
but you know detroit is like 75
democratic great so what you do is you
train a bunch of people to be poll
workers uh who know the process for
contesting ballots
say that i don't believe that this is a
valid voter you force them to have to
submit a contested ballot which then has
to be adjudicated and on and on and on
you train them up
and then
the list that the republican party
submits in detroit right they don't have
to do this everywhere you say we're
going to target detroit because that's
where we can make a difference it's so
many democrats will try to fight the
validity of democratic ballots for no
particular reason other than their
democrats the list that you submit in
detroit to the county to the election uh
uh clerk or
the the detroit official that chooses
the poll workers is all these people who
have been trained in bad faith not to
prevent fraud but to try to get votes in
detroit thrown out which are
overwhelmingly likely to be democratic
votes and so then
that's how you skew the results you let
the vote happen in other parts of
michigan that are more 50 50 or even the
rural parts of michigan which you're
republican
but in detroit you send this army of
poll workers who are actually bad faith
sort of like undercover political
operatives
to try to get democratic votes
discounted and they've got lawyers ready
they claim they're going to have police
chiefs ready now what is happening here
is that to win
they increasingly must cheat at least
apparently well why would that be
it's because on the issues the country
is moving more and more to the left
they're losing on the issues okay and by
the way i encourage you to listen to
these recordings in full there's an
eight-minute recording from an october
5th uh election integrity training
and then there's another 14-minute
recording
of a zoom meeting and you will very
quickly
understand the strategy
which we have
more or less explained here
if democrats wait until after it happens
it's going to be too late
and it's really important to understand
how
monumental the outcome of these midterms
will be
because in 2020 they had a bunch of
different strategies they tried uh it
was the national they have the can pence
overturn it alternate slates of electors
objections on january 6 all these
different things more than 60 court
cases which failed trying to prevent
mailing and absentee ballots they had
all these different things it didn't
work but it could have and now they're
going to refine the strategy and 2022 is
going to be a test of how much closer
can we get to just controlling the
election results by using these
techniques
so that in 2024 we might be able to just
get a president that didn't really win
installed in the white house
and there's a second layer to that
it's not just testing the techniques
it's also
can we use the techniques in 2022 we
being them
can we use the techniques in 2022
to get enough control over state
positions including secretaries of state
and governors etc
so that those individuals will be in
power in november of 2024
to maybe do what trump wanted
um brad raffensberger and brian kemp to
do
in georgia for example remember that i
need 11 000 votes give me a break
it didn't happen in georgia
but what about doug mastriano in
pennsylvania doug mastriano the now
winner of the republican gubernatorial
primary in pennsylvania
he's a big lie supporter and he's worse
than that by the way if you look at his
background
he might be willing
to do the things trump wanted them to do
in georgia in 2024 if he's the governor
so what if they use these techniques to
get masteriano in in 2022
so that he will be in power to do this
stuff in 2024. we cannot understate the
importance of these midterms so should
everyone vote of course that's number
one
but the democratic party
had better be ready to fight this now do
they have to fight fire with fire
meaning just set up democratic poll
workers to try to do this exact same
thing in republican areas well number
one i think that that's going low so i
don't think that's the way to do it and
number two by its nature
because republicans are more uh
predominant in rural areas with lower
populations
democrats are at a structural
disadvantage republicans can focus their
bad faith poll workers in the densely
populated areas
for democrats to fight that they would
need way more poll workers because you
would need them in way more precincts
because they're going to be more rural
precincts so
it's both a bad idea
and a difficult idea logistically
because of that so democrats need to
come up with something and i don't know
what the answer is i just learned about
this story yesterday i'm still thinking
about it but it is looking very very
rough let me know what you think find me
on twitter at dpakman and tuesday june
14th at 6 p.m will be the next david
pakman show town hall it'll stream live
on the pacman live youtube channel i'll
have more information on that uh between
now and then
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 percent off all products and free
shipping go to vincero
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below